[Music]
cameroon's indomitable lions score again
bringing victory to the national
football team in the african cup of
nations opening game against burkina
faso
it's really reassuring we're happy this
proves that we live up to our name the
lions we are really happy and emotional
with this victory
while burkina faso put up a fight some
of their best players were not on the
pitch but in their hotel rooms in
isolation after testing positive for
covid health workers woke them up for
tests on saturday night hours before the
game
much to the dismay of burkina faso's
team
according to the afcon health protocols
if i'm not mistaken the tests must be
carried out 48 hours before a match
we did the tests yesterday at 11 pm so
if my calculations are correct we will
not be within the 48 hours for
tomorrow's match
players from several african nations
including the favorite senegal have
tested positive hours after the opening
ceremony it seems omicron is already
overshadowing the event
the government spent almost a billion
dollars to host the african cup of
nations while fans are being tested
before entering the stadiums containing
the virus in a country where most are
unvaccinated and the health system is
underfunded will be a challenge
security is also a concern
english-speaking separatists were
responsible for bomb blasts last week in
limbe where several games are expected
to take place
there are also threats of attacks from
boko haram in the country's north
additional forces including the military
have been deployed to both regions
i can't reveal here the measures that
are being put in place but you should
know that afghan will also take place
under very good conditions there are no
varies there is nothing to worry about
despite the spread of covid and the
threat of attacks of armed groups
organizers say the show must go on
cameroon sees in the event an
opportunity to unite cameroonians and
for a brief 90 minutes forget about the
worries at home and enjoy the game
nicholas hawk al jazeera